a magnificent frame to reflect your
image pride is the name of this mirror
meant to represent one of the seven
deadly sins
porcelain flowers printed with images of
paper money are the expression of
avarice in these works by Barnaby
Barford The Observer becomes part of the
artwork they're decorative forms conceal
something more profound ruff is a
colorful explosion of red and yellow
while white ceramic flowers symbolize
sloth I wanted to explore what the seven
deadly sins meant in the beginning of
the 21st century so they've been around
since Pope Gregory wrote them down
instead of 600 AD so with without the
threat of eternal damnation I wanted to
see if they were still important in our
society
Barnaby bards works tells stories
there's a lot of hanky-panky going on in
this love nest
and even on his wedding day this groom
is already making eyes at another woman
Barford transforms kitschy porcelain
figures into attractive yet macabre
works with an ironic twist by bringing a
sort of sense of humor and irony to the
work I think it allows people to engage
with it on a different level than they
would if it was sort of deadly serious
and hammering a sort of message home at
his studio in London Barford cuts are
porcelain figurines he finds in junk
shops or on the Internet
then he pieces them together to create
something different but there's method
behind the seeming madness Barford
always has a very clear idea in mind and
his works poke fun at society
these objects are meant for something
completely different you know they're
meant to sort of celebrate the the sort
of romantic the chocolate box ideology
of life and in a way I'm using them to
sort of celebrate our foibles and our
royalties really he's made a name for
himself with installations like this one
called the Battle of Trafalgar in 2008
his figures even became the protagonists
of an animated film for British
television it recounts the tragic love
story of a pretty girl from high society
and a lower-class boy
I'm interested in the fact that we think
we're a very advanced society but
actually as human beings with exactly
the same as we were at the dawn of
society so our emotions and our
characteristics haven't changed it's
what makes us human Barford is a master
of his craft the Three Graces is a
favorite motif in art history Barford
recreates it with pop stars like Britney
Spears one person in three different
situations he did the same with Amy
Winehouse and Grace Jones he's making
these sculptures for a solo exhibition
in the US this fall Barford works are
sold by David Gill who owns a gallery in
London they're very varied it is many of
them are from the contemporary art world
that you see this contemporary
collectors some of them are very young
collectors barnaby Barford is successful
internationally but in many ways his art
is typically British a very British side
is the way of looking at a subject in a
satirical way of being able to make fun
of it
but also be kind of deadly serious about
it at the same time and his art does
just that it does away with conventional
logic and gets people talking
you